[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 23 avril le début
d'une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition
tout de suite les titres de ce set 8
journal les yvelines ont peint un
nouveau préfet jean jacques brot 62 ans
a pris à ses fonctions officiellement ce
matin il succède à serge morvan rester
en poste pendant deux ans et huit mois
et jean jacques brot connaît le
département le préfet a suivi des études
notamment à hec à jouy-en-josas
ce sont les 50 ans de mai-68 cette
période de grands mouvements sociaux en
france a résolument marqué les
consciences toute cette semaine nous
nous intéressons souvenirs à calais
c'est cet épisode dans le département
focus ce soir sur les yvelinois acteurs
de la mobilisation
et puis jusqu'à la fin avril les
yvelinoises sont appelés à participer à
rondot net une opération de ramassage
des déchets l'action est menée par le
comité départemental de la randonnée
pédestre des yvelines recevant sa
secrétaire générale jacqueline marinoni
invités de ce journal également mustapha
larbaoui le président de l'association
pharma citoyens l emmener à des jeunes
trappistes sur les plages du
débarquement à arromanches-les-bains
c'était la semaine dernière on en parle
tout à l'heure dans ce journal
une nouvelle journée de galère
aujourd'hui dans les transports les
cheminots ont entamé leur cinquième
phase de mouvement en pointillé pour
s'opposer à la réforme du rail la grève
à la sncf qui se poursuit donc demain à
mardi pour les voyageurs passant par
saint quentin en yvelines seat un train
sur trois pour le rer c est du côté de
la ligne l du transilien 2 trains sur 5
enfin du côté de la ligne u 7 1 train
sur 3 les infos et les horaires de vos
trains sont à retrouver sur le site
transilien tant qu'homme et jean jacques
brot est donc devenu le 19e préfet des
yvelines il a pris ses fonctions ce
lundi matin à versailles
après le départ de serge d'avant c'était
ce vendredi
ce dernier est resté en poste pendant
deux ans et huit mois les yvelines un
territoire que connaît bien le nouveau
préfet les précisions avec ce sujet
d'aurélie ronces
premiers pas sur le terrain en tant que
préfet des yvelines pour jean jacques
brot après un parcours riche qui lui a
permis notamment de travailler en outre
mer ou encore au japon
retour dans un département qu'il connaît
bien j'ai la chance d'y être étudiant à
hec ya quelques années dit passer mon
permis de conduire à versailles
j'habitais à jouy en josas quand vous
l'avez compris au vésinet aussi
ultérieurement dont je connais un peu le
département je connais plusieurs
personnalités éminentes de ce
département jeu très heureux d'y être en
poste même si jean jacques brot ne sait
pas encore combien de temps durera son
exercice à la tête de la préfecture des
yvelines
il connaît d'ores et déjà les enjeux de
notre département
il ya des dossiers de sociétés
extrêmement important des dossiers
d'urbanisme des dossiers religieux voilà
son est question grave qui mérite un
grand investissement est d'abord de ma
part beaucoup d'humilité de modestie
jean jacques brot succède à serge morvan
une fonction qu'il aura exercé pendant
deux ans et huit mois et qui aura marqué
sa mémoire
malheureusement il ya eu l'attentât de
magnanville j'ai passé la nuit
cette rue vraiment je ne vais pas
m'étendre lamé et je veux pas revenir
là-dessus mais c'était très difficile
l'ancien préfet dû quitter ses fonctions
vendredi dernier non sans un petit
pincement au coeur
bon jeu principal regret c'est de partir
je serais bien rester encore longtemps
dans les yvelines comme préfet des
yvelines
il ya encore tellement de choses à faire
nommé commissaire général à l'égalité
des territoires serge normand aura en
charge la préfiguration de la future
agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires
c'était il ya 50 ans les mouvements
sociaux de mai 68 ont marqué l'histoire
contemporaine cette semaine notre
dossier de la rédaction est consacrée à
cette thématique rencontre ce soir avec
deux yvelinois pierre déjean et jean
pierre wolf était à l'époque
respectivement étudiants et ouvriers
chez renault à boulogne billancourt
reportage de nicolas landry et camille
lambert l'a bien entendu c'est
l'inévitable réunion de des étudiants en
comité d'action une réunion à laquelle a
participé pierre dejean en mai 1968 cet
habitant de montigny le bretonneux à 19
ans il est étudiant en génie électrique
à l'iut de ville d'avray
les affrontements entre étudiants et
policiers le 10 mai 1968 ont déclenché
la mobilisation dans cet établissement
le gouvernement à cette époque là d'un
le le 10 mai a fait un acte d'autorité
qui n'était pas justifié et on a fait le
tour des classes qui était déjà donc
entamé puis on a dit écoutez il ya parmi
eux des événements importants
cette nuit une répression assez dur faut
au moins qu'on fasse quelque chose on
fait on fait une manifestation à bild à
brac la mobilisation ne s'arrête pas là
des professeurs de l'iut se joignent au
mouvement
les cours sont arrêtés la grève est
lancé malgré l'opposition de certains
étudiants
on a vibré coûté ont fait pas grève on
suspend les cours ce qui est exactement
la même chose mais pour d'autres qu'il
voulait pas s'engager pas ça permet
effectivement date ou tard et paie des
photos des journaux ou des caricatures
pierre dejean conserve de nombreux
souvenirs des mobilisations sociales
notamment la manifestation du 13 mai
1968 à paris
slogan commun qui est scandé pendant
cette même station ses 10 ans ça suffit
10 ans ça suffit la société
effectivement très bloqués on parlait
fallait que ça change quoi fallait que
ça change
le changement c'était aussi la
principale revendication des ouvriers de
l'usiné renault à billancourt
jean pierre wolf avait 30 ans à l'époque
il vivait à versailles et travailler sur
l'outillage il produisait des machines
pour fabriquer des voitures sur l'île
seguin la mobilisation a commencé le 16
mai à boulogne on a des idées de
d'arrêter le travail et que les
étudiants sont ni bons nous dire comment
vous les faire c'est là on leur a dit
nous on joue pas le jeu lun vous êtes
chez vous on est chez nous des
revendications distincte des étudiants
comme l'amélioration des conditions de
travail la hausse des salaires ou encore
plus de protection sociale
l'augmentation générale des salaires
pour toutes les catégories
c'est albert était le secrétaire du
syndicat jean pierre wolf se souvient du
mouvement à l'intérieur de l'usiné
tout comme le travail sur les machines
la mobilisation s'est faite avec son
binôme
on a mis nos ballerines en état de
[Musique]
de propreté de conservation s'immoler
puisque on allait permettre le boulot
tout de suite
donc on les a nettoyés comme il fallait
qu'il soit et puis on les aigles
évidemment les un état et puis on a
commencé à occuper l'usiné
on en doute 33 34 jaune me rappelle plus
combien de temps sa bulle on a dormi la
bonne nuit sur deux le 17 juin 1968 la
reprise du travail est votée
jean pierre wolf et ses confrères ont
obtenu notamment une hausse de leurs
salaires
douze jeunes et 12 seniors de trappes en
visite en normandie ils se sont rendus
la semaine dernière à or
arromanches-les-bains l'un des
principaux lieux du débarquement des
alliés en 1944
bonsoir mustapha larfaoui bonsoir vous
êtes le président de formats citoyens
c'est cette association justement qui
organisait donc cette sortie en
normandie on va en parler dans un
instant peut-être déjà rappelé ce qui
est format citoyens beaucoup d'action
pour cette association on a couvert
notamment récemment une journée au
théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une visite
également au musée
c'était au musée national de la sécurité
sociale a bordeaux il ya un message fort
qui a véhiculé par l'association c'est
la solidarité
alors c'est la solidarité qui est un des
piliers finalement de ce qu'est la
citoyenneté la citoyenneté c'est se sait
devenir celui qu'on doit être et en même
temps c'est faire en sorte que tous les
individus vivent avec bordeaux avec le
bien commun donc c'est la notion de
citoyenneté et la solidarité est un
élément fondateur et structurant donc la
sécu à une époque c'était une manière de
dire voilà la sécu quand on en a besoin
c'est important mais il faut en prendre
soin avant et on fait ça en véhicule
soit au travers du foot ce qui fait
qu'on a des images donc dans le foot
c'est on donne la balle on reçoit la
balle comme on donne les cotisations et
on reçoit les soins quand nécessaire au
prestigieux là vous avez été président
de trappes pendant de l'étoile sportive
par ap pendant mes l'heure c'est ça mais
la symbolique est importante sachant
qu'on s'adresse à des enfants et que
l'idée c'est du loisir consommer non pas
consommer à atif comme on pourrait dire
mais du loisir éducatif
donc oui son frère à d'autres horizons
aussi dans la saison donc pharma
citoyens comme son nom indique ses fins
la pharmacie
j'ai quand même un lieu de 1 lieu de
santé un lieu de solidarité un lieu où
on peut trouver toujours quelqu'un pour
apporter du soin mais l'idée c'est que
les gens viennent à nous les pharmaciens
je considère que les pharmaciens peuvent
aller également vers les autres doudous
le pharmacien citoyens et donc pharma
citoyens et donc plusieurs actions sont
menées ont fait également du renfort
maths français avec les réformes parce
qu'elle fait beaucoup de dons de
matériel médical donc ça sert beaucoup
ici en français et à l'étranger ont fait
beaucoup de sorties avec nos enfants
bacon à condition que ce soit éducatif
accompagné des seniors parce que j'aime
l'idée du lien intergénérationnel
vous avez fait un magnifique reportage
sur mai 68 je crois qu'il faut savoir
reconnaître à la fois ce que les anciens
nous apporte est pas tout le temps se
consacrer au jeunisme comme je le dis ce
qui est important c'est qu'ils aient des
liens entre les uns et les autres
donc l'histoire c'est important d'où
notre sortie à arromanches et pour le
coup tous les enfants étaient subjugués
par cette aventure humaine l'idée c'est
de montrer que voilà il ya chez l'humain
l'horreur si on se laisse dériver et je
trouve qu'on cesse souvent un peu trop
dériver et l'humanité l'a prouvé et en
même temps l'humain est capable de
choses extraordinaires et et grandiose
ce devoir de mémoire c'est important
pour être justement un bon citoyen il
faut avoir ce cette mémoire voilà un
citoyen je disais tout à l'heure c'est
bien évidemment faire ce que l'on
veut faire ce que l'on veut ce que l'on
doit devenir mais avoir toujours ce
respect d'autrui ce respect de connaître
à la fois de connaître l'autre et de
renaître avec l'autre et ça passe par
l'histoire la connaissance de l'histoire
et puis encore une fois je vous dis
l'homme est capable du pire et de son
contraire et ça ça ça se voit au travers
des des témoignages qu'on a pu
recueillir le lors du lors des débats
qu'on a eue lors des conférences qui a
pu y avoir 1 re manche ça séduit les
enfants
il faut arrêter de penser que les
enfants il faut uniquement les emmener à
la piscine à vagues ou dans des endroits
de consommation d'autres le font c'est
important d'autres font ce genre de 2,2
de deux sorties de loisirs
nous on se consacre à ce qui me paraît
essentiel pour la citoyenneté donc ça
fait partie du souvenir ça fait partie
l'histoire ont fait partie oui et en
même temps il ya toujours un message est
que ce que l'on fait et du sens le
football c'est un bon moyen de départ
pour véhicules et d'autres messages
ces jeunes jouent au football mais ils
peuvent tout à fait mans l'envahissement
par exemple arromanches c'est comment on
est sorti mais il ya eu des tas de pays
dans le monde qui ont été envahies et
comment on en sort l'envahissement est
relativement facile dans l'histoire
c'est comment on en sort et parfois je
m'amuse à dire ben il ya des
envahissement de terrain aussi
au foot on voit tout sait tous ces gens
dans les tribunes qu'ils sont capables
d'envoyer des terrains il ya quelque
chose de sacré en allant à
l'envahissement et donc comment on en
sort et comment on le prévient voilà
donc ce n'est pas un discours uniquement
pour nos enfants des cités c'est un
discours qu'on peut avoir pour tous les
enfants de la nation quel que soit le
lieu où ils habitent et de là où ils ont
grandi parce que je trouve que
l'injustice n'est pas celle qu'on croit
c'est pas celle qui consiste à dire il
n'y a pas suffisamment de loisirs pour
ces gens là c'est que dans d'autres
lieux de vie beaucoup plus on va dire
plus riches beaucoup moins modestes
c'est ça qu'on enseigne aussi
moi j'étais frappé quand j'étais enfant
de voir les gosses de riches les gosses
de bourges comme on les appelait à les
casser des cailloux
pendant les vacances en rose allait
restaurer des maisons où travailler
gratuitement pour des entrepreneurs je
comprenais pas pourquoi on est bon on
esclavagisés les gosses de les gosses de
riches
il ne reste pas fait tirer un message
mustapha larbaoui juste sur les
prochaines actions il ya une sortie qui
sera organisée à berlin où elle même
style pareil c'est culturel c'est
l'apprentissage c'est la reconnaissance
et la 9e la première verdun par exemple
parce qu'on va commémorer
le centenaire en parler de mai 68 à
l'heure mais c'est également le
centenaire de la fin de la guerre 1918
et donc tout ça ce sont des messages
comme c'est fait dans d'autres familles
plus aisées et qui pense à ces choses là
alors je considère qu'on met des moyens
dans cette direction là pour ses moyens
on ne manquera pas de suivre cette
prochaine si encore merci à mustapha
larbaoui président de l'association
pharma citoyens et vous pouvez suivre
l'actualité de cette association sur la
page facebook qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran on parlait citoyenneté être un
bon citoyen c'est aussi respecter
l'environnement près de 800 millions de
tonnes de déchets sont produits chaque
année en france beaucoup se retrouvent
dans la nature
en avril le comité départemental de la
randonnée pédestre des mines invite les
clubs à participer à rando net c'est une
opération de nettoyage des sentiers
reportage de camille lambert bouteilles
en verre sacs plastiques cartons ces
déchets peuvent mettre plusieurs
centaines d'années à disparaître dans la
nature
armés de gants et de sacs poubelles
c'est 15 randonneurs de la ls elancourt
ont prévu de nettoyer les abords du
sentier sont majoritairement sur le bord
des routes et aux abords des villes est
en fait chaud les chemins surtout le jeu
des conseils de ville les chemins sont
relativement propres fait les
randonneurs sont des gens qui respectent
la nature départ lancé au mesnil saint
denis
à peine quelques mètres et déjà des
trouvailles et plastique plastic
l'association participe à l'opération
rando net lancé par le comité de la
randonnée pédestre des yvelines un moyen
de sensibiliser le public au respect de
la nature
le trajet se poursuit jusqu'à l'église
de lévis en bouteilles et autres
du papier d'alu du plastique hochart
papier c'est principalement ça des
petits morceaux plastique c'est pas
énorme comme collecte positive du coup
oui pour les chemins c'est positif que
les chemins le savez que c'est positif
un maigre butin synonyme de bonnes
nouvelles pour la nature car chaque
année près de 800 millions de tonnes de
déchets sont produits en france
nouvelles invitent avec moi en plateau
jacqueline marino nier bonsoir mon choix
vous êtes la secrétaire générale du
comité départemental de la randonnée
pédestre des yvelines qu'on appelle
aussi le co des randos 78 alors le
comité on l'a vu dans ce reportage est à
l'origine de cette opération
rando net est ce que les clubs de
randonnée des éminents ont répondu à
votre appel en ce mois d'après à 60 %
oui en fait nous faisons appel à eux
pour sortir dédié une sortie en honnête
donc tous les adhérents viennent et
participe volontiers à cette opération
ça fait plusieurs années juste donc le
code héros doit la lancer pourquoi la
thématique l'environnement du respect de
l'environnement et cher pour le coc des
randos alors si la quatrième édition
c'est vrai mais là le respect de la
nature et l'environnement fait un peu
partie de l'adn du randonneur
donc nous avons voulu lancer cette
opération pour faire voir au public le
public est invité également participé à
ces opérations pour faire voir que ce
marché dans le propre finalement c'est
beaucoup plus agréable que avoir des
détritus qui se promène un peu partout
malheureusement non vous disais quand on
est passionné de randonnées qu'on en
fait souvent le respect de la nature ça
va de soi c'est on est attaché au
respect de la nature
absolument oui tout à fait on fait très
attention à ne verrez rien laisser
derrière nous et on voudrait diffuser en
fait cette opération dans le public
également
quand on l'a vu dans le reportage les
beaux jours sont de retour c'est
l'occasion de parler des randonnées
pédestres dans les yvelines de manière
plus
général quand on veut faire de la
randonnée pédestre dans les yvelines il
ya 1300 km d'itinéraires balisés les
yvelines
on peut le dire c'est un terrain idéal
pour un très beau stade c'est très vert
et le comité justement s'attache à faire
des parcours en appui en partenariat
avec le conseil départemental bien sûr
des yvelines donc nous traçons des
parcours qui mixtent un peu le l'urbain
et le rural sociaux et la particularité
saml urbain et nature il ya beaucoup de
son patrimoine
absolument il ya beaucoup de patrimoine
et
quelquefois bon les gens font un circuit
sans forcément connaître ce qu'il ya à
100 m en fait un petit détour et on
découvre quelque chose de magnifique
donc on avait sorti le on a sorti le
topo des yvelines l'année dernière qui
prend des parcours justement les décrit
peut dire c'est la bible de la randonnée
dans les yvelines où on y trouve
qu'est ce qu'on y trouve dans ce livre
on y trouve des parcours de toutes les
longueurs qui sont adaptées aussi bien
aux chevronnées qu'aux débutants balade
avec enfin ou sans peu importe je suis
rené débutant ce que c'est aussi
important de le dire on peut faire de la
randonnée de manière différente ça peut
être une simple balade mais ça peut être
à un niveau beaucoup plus élevé bien sûr
il ya déjà la vitesse qui compte et puis
la longueur évidemment il faut pas
s'imaginer que les yvelines ses plats il
ya des dénivelés non certaines régions
vous allez dans la farine meudon en bord
de seine évidemment ses plans mais il ya
des niches les fonds portuaires sera
menée avec la famile aussi à des clubs
de randonnée pédestre
absolument on a 47 clubs qui nous sont
affiliés 4300 adhérents
et dans les parcours on peut faire en
boucle on choisit sa distance avec une
partie découverte évidemment on a mis le
300 kilomètres avec qui se dit donc que
vous avez amené avec vous on peut se le
procurer ou à la fédération française de
randonnée pédestre ou soon sur notre
site également qui s'allège de
actuellement il faut suivre les balises
évidemment on a
une équipe de 96 baliseurs qui rénovent
les balises alors souvent les gens
voient lebanese ils font pas forcément
le rattachement avec la avec les vols
intérieurs
absolument et une équipe de bénévoles
vraiment qu'ils veillent en plus sur
l'état des sentiers qui les remettent
enfin en état
quelle importance il à ce travail
justement des bénévoles de ce travail de
balisage 1300 km on disait tout à
l'heure des itinéraires balisés quelle
importance du travail c'est une vraie
veille en fait qu'on fait sur ces
sentiers
il y à un arbre qui s'est couché au
milieu du parcours on le signale il ya
le suricate le la plateforme en fait
pour signaler les désagréments qu'il ya
sur un sentier d'accord tous les
sentiers sont sécurisés ont fait bien
attention de qu'il n'y a pas de passage
dangereux et c'est donc en suivant les
balises
normalement on chemine en toute
tranquillité et on veille
il ya les quelques fois elles sont
cachés par la végétation par le lierre
et c'est donc les balises en charge et
le nettoyer donc daisy tiers dont deux
nés retrouvés dans ce livre les yvelines
à pied il ya aussi des possibilités sur
votre site internet on peut retrouver
des fiches sur sur les randonnées
absolument tout ce qui n'est pas décrit
en donner en circuit dans ce taux paul
les sur le site également un agenda avec
toutes les sorties organisées par les
les clubs de randonnée absolument il ya
les idées de sorties pour les idées de
sorties dans le département et aux
départements environnants alors avec
souvent des des liens festif des fêtes
autour de la randonnée qui se font ou
des idées de deux parcours avec des
découvertes spécifique des animations
spécifiques
il nous reste 30 secondes un dernier mot
peut-être des conseils
quels conseils vous pourriez donner à
quelqu'un alors qu'il n'a pas l'habitude
de faire de la randonnée qui voudraient
faire de la randonnée lancement avoir de
bonnes chaussures
la bouteille d'eau un sac à dos et c'est
parti c'est tout à fait simple ça fait
du bien à la santé aussi au moral et
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur la randonnée pédestre
dans les yvelines sur le site du coc des
randos et qui s'affiche en bas d'écran
merci à jacqueline marinoni d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes la
secrétaire générale du comité
départemental de la randonnée pédestre
des yvelines le sport olympique lyonnais
stade rennais ou encore étoile sportive
de trapèze étaient 81 80 équipes de
filles et de garçons à participer au
tour qualificatif de la danone nations
cup le tournoi mondial des 10-12 ans en
faisait étape s'allier à clairefontaine
qg des sélections française de football
une équipe masculine et une féminine de
trappes était de la partie elles ont
terminé respectivement 28e et 36e jouer
au même endroit que les pros un rêve
pour les jeun's yvelinois présents ainsi
que pour leurs parents
propos recueillis par nicolas landry oui
il ya beaucoup d'adversité
mais on essaye de donner le maximum de
nous pour pour essayer d'aller le plus
loin possible
bah ça fait toujours plaisir parce que
c'est ça le drame des pros ils ont joué
enfin qui jouent et ah bah voilà c'est
bien
beaucoup d'émotion on voit beaucoup de
choses des enfants enfin c'est très
plaisant de voir autant d'enfants jouer
avec des grandes équipes c'est vraiment
très très très intéressant de participer
à cet événement le paris fc l'ol le
stade rennais et dijon au côté garçons
et toulouse l'ol le havre et paris fc
pour les filles se sont qualifiés pour
la finale nationale c'est le 20 mai
prochain à montpellier
les jeunes de trappes eux sont repartis
avec le prix du fair play
l'équipe une senior de trapel joué hier
dimanche un match en retard dans le
championnat de r4 elle recevait les
gobelins une rencontre qui s'est
terminée sur le score de 1 but partout
ce qui n'arrange pas les trappistes dans
la course au maintien
résumé du match nicolas landry et miquel
et demi d'euros une égalisation dans les
ultimes secondes de la partie les rouges
de trappes y ont cru jusqu'au bout ce
dimanche 22 avril contre l'équipe des
gobelins en match en retard du
championnat de régionale 4 pourtant tout
avait mal débuté pour les trappistes
dominé en début de partie ils concèdent
l'ouverture du score mettra pas fait
preuve de caractère en égalisant face au
leader du championnat
score final un but partout on se dit
quand on a trois sont plus rien à perdre
la preuve sur un dernier coup de pied
arrêté notre gardien est monté on se
contentait pas de doute la défaite on on
voulait absolument arracher le point du
match nul et voire même la victoire mais
pas s'étendre
malheureusement au matin venu
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de ya pas
une banque les joueurs ont tout donné
alors plus est la chaleur certains
couples que c'est pour nous la moue de
mon côté je vends pas de rire parce
qu'ils ont tout d'un coup qu'on a fait
ce qu'il fallait avant tout donner un
but à la 90e minute qui pourraient avoir
une importance cruciale pour la suite du
championnat trap est actuellement 12e
sur 14 équipes engagées dont qui n'aura
cependant cinq matches on a encore trois
domiciles
qu'on prenne des points le plus
rapidement possible pour assurer le
maintien qui était pas l'objectif de
début de saison mais vu les événements
de fer avec ea voilà le sien c'est un
bon match pour nous mais en fait non
quand on fait un match en retard
donc cette famille de reste de gagner
encore en vrac et quoi en fait un trois
points donc là nous ferons quand deux
victoires pour assurer le maintien pour
la première de ses cinq finales à
disputer d'ici la fin de la saison les
trappistes se dépasseront ce dimanche 29
avril sur le terrain de val de france
une équipe classée dernière de ce
championnat
alors reste de l'actualité sportive
revinoise à suivre juste après ce
journal dans le 7-8 sport présentée par
michael et demi d'euros avant de
refermer ce journal il retourne à
l'école 20 artistes réalisateurs
comédiens reviennent cette année dans
leurs lieux d'apprentissage un temps
d'échangé avec les élèves de
l'établissement
le 9 avril la dernier c'était le
réalisateur frédéric tellier qui se
prêtait à l'exercice au collège raymond
poincaré de versailles
retour sur cet après midi avec patrick
jacques de dixmude et mélanie poker
frédéric tellier au milieu des élèves le
temps d'une photo et d'un échange et
c'est dans son collège raymond poincaré
de versailles qui partage son amour du
septième art il n'y a pas forcément
besoin de faire une école du cinéma
personnellement j'ai même toujours
refusé d'aller faire des master classes
dans les écoles de cinéma pour cette
raison là je pense que la meilleure
école c'est celle du tas je suis revenu
avec l'idée à leur faire passer que me
mois pour le moment toute ma vie aura
été habité par l'idée de la culture et
de partager la culture
que ce soit du divertissement où la
culture des films plus grave ou plus
légers pas que ça embellit la vie on vit
mieux
saint john perse disait j'écris pour
mieux vivre moi je fais du cinéma pour
mieux vivre
le réalisateur de l'affairé skah 1 et
les hommes de l'ombre participe à la
septième édition d'un artiste à l'école
une édition parrainée cette année par
julie gayet l'idée c'est de montrer aux
élèves qui sont actuellement dans le
collège que
certains des anciens élèves ont eu un
parcours remarquable et que donc voilà
ils peuvent espérer s'appuyer sur
l'expérience qu'ils ont déjà dans le
collège et voilà envisager de vidéos
tout simplement un collège qui a
développé des vocations artistiques
raymond poincaré a vu grandir
l'intouchable eric toledano et l'auteur
chanteur gaêl faille
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal bonne
soirée et excellente semaine à tous sur
tv 78
[Musique]